now
weeks of high heat and little rain being
blamed for several firefight
fires in the western united states and
the biggest one is the oak fire it's in
northern california near yosemite
national park trinity chavez reporting
how firefighters are finally though
starting to get this one under control
the oak fire raging on in california's
bone dry brush now for the fifth
consecutive day
in a statement released last night cal
fire said it was a successful day for
aircraft and firefighters resulting in
minimal growth on the fire this morning
we reported 10 percent containment on
the fire
tonight we're reporting 16 containment
so you know it's not a huge number but
it's a pretty big percentage jump the
oak fire broke out friday and quickly
spread to over 17 thousand acres just
west of yosemite national park it's
already destroyed more than 50 homes and
other buildings while forcing thousands
of residents to evacuate i'm exhausted
i am just very exhausted officials said
dry windy conditions in the area helped
fuel the flames which followed the path
of a major 2018 wildfire it's actually
buttoned up against an old burn scar the
old ferguson fire so that has slowed it
down the vegetation there is
is not as dense as it is where it has
not burned while in texas at least 20
homes have been damaged or completely
destroyed in a grass fire that spread
across a suburban dallas field
investigators believe it may have been
started by a spark from a lawnmower
blade that struck an object on the
ground trinity chavez cbs news new york
let's bring it home here let's look at
what's going on in nevada
represented by red circles on the map
that's where the fires are within our
state the larger the circle the larger
the fire fire and you can see there are
several incidents here most of them
though happening in the northern part of
the state